china may have a zero covid policy but
it's becoming clear it didn't have much
of a zero covered plan it was miserable
enough in the shanghai quarantine center
before but it's so shortly built that
the rainwater is soaking the people's
the city's lockdown remains in place
bringing china's financial center and a
major international trade hub to a
standstill
and experts have told sky news that
china's unflinching pursuit of covet
zero could have an impact beyond its
borders on global supply chains and the
cost of living
this isn't just about shanghai china's
tight covert controls all around the
country mean the movement of goods has
been strangled by checks as laurie
drivers on the border of beijing told
sky news
[Applause]
[Music]
drivers doors are given official seals
like this to prove they haven't left
their cabin in cities and risked
infection
a motorway
in beijing might seem the last place you
really need to worry about but what
happens here could actually have massive
ripple effects in terms of supply chains
across the world
but for all the current difficulties the
real nightmare would be other cities in
china also going into full lockdown
cameron johnson is a supply chain expert
who's been locked down in shanghai for
more than a month now down south go goes
offline guangzhou shenzhen
if shanghai continues to stay offline if
another area goes offline then you will
start to see massive global
effects in the supply chain and they
won't be easily resolved and those
global effects will lead to people all
around the world paying more for goods
not just paying more but companies won't
have revenue it's not going to be pretty
china would say that its covet zero
policy is the only thing stopping the
country being overwhelmed by the disease
and that would have even worse effects
for global supply chains
right now it is the citizens of china
who are experiencing the worst
but the rest of the world may not be
sheltered either tom cheshire sky news
beijing